let's get into this week's hatred mail
if you've never heard hatred mail before
it's when a professional
narrator professional voice-over artist
does interpretive readings of the hate
mail that I get here's a little more
information about hey treat male hey
let's face it
the only logical response to guns is
more freaking guns Patriot Man written
by Patriots who hate David Pakman
because America and because freedom okay
so this week's hatred mail like many
uses a lot of the buzz words that are
frequently parts of hatred mail but it
actually introduces a term that I don't
know if it could come from some kind of
faulty autocorrect of my last name but
it does make me room it reminisce about
my youth take a listen to this and see
if you can spot it great blanket
statement by a massively biased
propagator David Walkman being a
regressive like yourself is aligned with
men who are absurdly beta tragic stuff
David Pakman is clearly a beta Chuck
because he looks like he showers
regularly David you are so stupid you
don't even know that you are a socialist
yes so once again with the I'm actually
a socialist and don't even realize it
explained to me how I'm getting slammed
by those who say I should be a socialist
and by those who are saying I am a
socialist but when I saw instead of
David Parkman instead of whatever other
insults David Walkman
I actually am of an age where the
Walkman was phasing out as I was in my
youth and this is completely foreign to
you right Pat I mean you have no idea
what these portable portable tape
players are I mean I know what it is
because I've seen old TV shows but that
wasn't part of my generation I grew up
with iPods yeah it was back when the
world was still in black and white that
they still uh they still use those make
patriots cry by using the coupon code
hey tree at forty when you get a member
ship at WWJ Ockman calm you go to that
website join pakman.com select the
membership of your choice when presented
with the option to enter a coupon code
you tape in hey tree at 40 h atri OT 4-0
this saves you 40% and it sends a
message to the hey tree it's it's a
middle finger really to the hatreds that
says you will not be intimidated by
their insults and you are supporting the
david pakman show thank you